[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia el reino de jordania en el
medio oriente protagonizó una crisis la
noticia de las acusaciones del gobierno
en contra el príncipe hamza señalando lo
de complot contra el rey abdalá segundo
reavivó una trama palaciega un entramado
de reyes y príncipes herederos al
príncipe hamza bin husein se lo acusa de
tener contactos en el extranjero y
también de relacionarse con líderes
beduinos opositores para desestabilizar
el reino aunque el palacio afirma que
hamza prometió permanecer leal al rey
abdalá segundo son conocidos sus
desencuentros por denuncias de
corrupción manejo de la economía e
incluso de la misma pandemia este
ajedrez de la realeza no es la primera
vez que ocurre la historia de la
monarquía jordana comprende traiciones
intrigas y reyes que cambian a su antojo
de sucesor veamos en el informe de maría
clara calle un recuento de aquellos
momentos de fricción en la col
de jordania
la constitución de jordania es clara el
primer hijo del rey será el heredero
pero en el país árabe esto puede
modificarse si el monarca lo quiere como
ocurrió cuatro veces durante el mandato
de joxe y desde que asumió la corona en
1952 una de sus primeras decisiones fue
nombrar a su hermano mohamed para que lo
sucediera en el trono diez años después
le quitó ese poder y nombró como
príncipe heredero a su hijo recién
nacido
abdulá en 1965 cuando el niño tenía tan
sólo tres años el rey hussein modificó
otra vez la línea de sucesión y puso de
primero a su hermano hassan el tío de
abdulá la decisión fue motivada por la
atención política de medio oriente es el
país estaba camino a participar en la
guerra de los seis días en la que
perdería el control sobre cisjordania
así hassan se convirtió en la mano
derecha del rey hussein y lo apoyó
durante más de tres décadas incluso fue
él quien lideró al país cuando al
monarca le descubrieron un cáncer
linfático
pero ese fue el momento en el que se
quebró la relación hussein viajó a eeuu
para tratar su enfermedad y allí se
enteró de que su hermano hassan intentó
expulsar a los militares que eran más
leales al reino la ira del monarca fue
tal que a su regreso a jordania en enero
de 1999 también por cuarta vez la
sucesión al trono y volvió a nombrar a
su hijo abdalá hussein murió tres
semanas después el rey abdalá segundo
quiso complacer a su padre fallecido y
de manera inmediata nombró a su medio
hermano hamza como príncipe heredero a
pesar de que los dos eran muy distintos
pero con el tiempo la sombra del rey
hussein se fue extinguiendo y en 2004
abdalá quitó de la línea de sucesión a
su hermano hamza el rey le escribió una
carta en la que le decía que lo liberaba
de las limitaciones de ser el príncipe
heredero y cinco años después ratificó a
su propio hijo en la línea de sucesión
fue así como se abrió una herida que
nunca ha sanado en el poder de jordania
el sistema de gobierno de jordania es
una monarquía constitucional el actual
rey abdalá el segundo es el cuarto en la
historia política de este joven reino
que ocupa una de las tierras más
interesantes del medio oriente cruce de
civilizaciones jordania comenzó el siglo
20 siendo parte del imperio turco
otomano hasta que en 1918 los británicos
la ocuparon en calidad de mandato sólo
hasta 1946 después de la segunda guerra
mundial
jordania obtuvo su total independencia
con un tratado concluyente en londres
tres años después una nueva constitución
fue promulgada y el nombre del estado se
decantó por el de reino hachemita de
jordania haciendo alusión a la dinastía
hachemita que traza su origen desde la
época de mahoma el 15 de mayo de 1948 un
día después de que la onu proclamará la
creación del estado independiente de
israel en los territorios de la
palestina jordania se unió a sus vecinos
árabes para declararle la guerra en ese
entonces fungía como rey
dalla quien expulsó a las fuerzas judías
de jerusalén del este y se anexionó la
región palestina al oeste del río jordán
llamada cisjordania
el rey abdalá fue asesinado en la
mezquita de al aqsa en jerusalén el 20
de julio de 1951 por un nacionalista
palestino quien lo sucedió fue su hijo
talal pero dada su incapacidad mental
para gobernar abdicó a la vez en favor
de su hijo
hussein con hussein de rey jordania fue
un territorio que alojó a los palestinos
desprovistos de un estado
su causa cobraba fuerza entre los más
radicales y el crecimiento de la
organización para la liberación de
palestina y el grupo militante fatá
comenzó a representar una potencia la
amenaza contra la soberanía jordana y la
estabilidad del reino por eso tras haber
perdido en cuestión de horas la guerra
de los seis días en 1967
jordania viró de política renunció a las
tierras de cisjordania y de jerusalén
del este
anexionadas ahora por israel y dejó de
luchar de una cierta manera por la causa
palestina
de hecho en 1974 hussein prometió que
nunca más se aliaría con una federación
de palestinos la paz con israel fue
esquiva durante esos años pero se logró
en 1994 poniendo fin a 46 años de estado
de guerra desde entonces y a pesar de
dolorosos capítulos de terrorismo
jordania en su calidad de monarquía
constitucional se destaca entre sus
vecinos árabes por su estabilidad y
progreso en una de las regiones más
convulsas del mundo el medio oriente
llegamos de esta manera al final soy
andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir y comentar estas historias que
las encuentran en los programas de
france 24 punto com
[Música]